[Musique]
parade militaire géante ce mardi à new
delhi sous le regard du premier ministre
indien la reine g audi chargé troupe des
fils mais à quelques kilomètres de là
une changement d'ambiance
[Applaudissements]
la police indienne chargée tirent des
gaz lacrymogènes en face des milliers
d'agriculteurs indiens manifestent avec
leurs tracteurs en ce 26 janvier la
police tire des gaz lacrymogènes sur
nous une frappe avec des bâtons on
voulait protester pacifiquement avec les
couleurs de notre drapeau national
on n'a rien fait de mal c'est la police
qui a tiré des gaz lacrymogènes et nous
a frappés avec des matraques
les autorités avaient pourtant autorisé
la manifestation à condition de laisser
le défilé militaire se dérouler comme
prévu jusqu'à la fin mais rapidement les
forces de sécurité ont été débordés et
les agriculteurs sont parvenus à forcer
certains barrages dressés à l'entrée de
new delhi
des milliers d'entre eux sont même
parvenus à occuper le fort rouge l'un
des monuments les plus emblématiques et
les plus sécurisés de delhi depuis fin
novembre des dizaines de milliers
d'agriculteurs comme sur les principaux
axes routiers au port de la capitale
indienne
ils réclament la révocation des lois
libéralisant les marchés agricoles a
adopté en septembre par le gouvernement
maudit pour faire simple les
agriculteurs indiens peuvent désormais
vendre leurs produits à des acheteurs
privés sans passer par les bandits ces
marchés locaux réglementé ou l'état
garantit un prix de vente minimal des
denrées de base principalement le blé le
riz un désengagement de l'état mal
perçues par les agriculteurs
craignant d'être laissé à la merci des
grandes entreprises malgré plusieurs
tentatives de négociations entre
syndicats agricoles et le gouvernement
aucune solution n'a été trouvée le
message pour le premier ministre c'est
que ce n'est pas le gouvernement indien
c'est le gouvernement des agriculteurs
etc les agriculteurs qui vont le
gouverner nous ferons ce que nous
voulons vous ne pouvez pas forcer vos
lois sont les pauvres selon vos propres
caprice le 12 janvier dernier la cour
suprême indienne plus haute juridiction
du pays a suspendu l'application des
réformes agricoles jusqu'à nouvel ordre
annonçant dans le même temps la
formation d'un comité d'experts pour
faciliter la médiation entre
agriculteurs et gouvernement ce dernier
a proposé un gel de la lisant neuf de
ses lois pour les 18 prochains mois
pas de quoi calmer la colère des
agriculteurs pour autant qu'ils exigent
leur abrogation pure et simple